kristen stewart is engaged to her
girlfriend dylan meyer after two years
together for me at this point
it's a pretty happy place the 31 year
old actress revealed the big news during
her appearance on the howard stern show
on tuesday and said it was dylan who
popped the question
and it seems like the twilight star has
known the screenwriter was the one for a
while now back in november 2019 she told
howard she was in love and couldn't wait
to be together forever are you in love
right now
yeah you are like like
yeah i mean the answer is yes will you
propose absolutely when i can't [ __ ]
wait really yeah i don't know it's big
yeah i want to be like sort of somewhat
reasonable about it but i think like
good things happen fast and yeah and get
this the two actually met working on a
movie years ago but things didn't get
romantic until they reconnected six
years later she like rocked up at a
friend's birthday party and i was like
where have you been and how have i not
known you two weeks later kristen said
she dropped the l word on dylan it was
like really late we were in some like
bar and her friends were there or
whatever and they like walked out and i
was just like oh man i'm so in love with
you like done since then the two have
been going strong back in april dylan
penned a sweet tribute to her leading
lady on her 31st birthday posting this
pic alongside the caption quote life
sure is sweeter with this cute little
family happy birthday kiddo you knock my
socks off
that was sick dude e.t recently caught
up with kristen who plays the late
princess diana in the film spencer
there's no hope for me
and she said playing the devoted mom of
two had her thinking about having her
own children one day
well i have a dog and i'm sure that like
uh when i have children ultimately i'll
realize that this is um you know that
there is i have room to go but i think
that this is tippy top just like i do
love my dog quite a lot
for me at this point
it's a pretty happy place i mean i'm a
kid of a of a parent um
i do know what it feels like that is
that exchanges you know i can't say with
certainty that anybody feels like to be
a mother but i have you know
i have all the natural feelings i am a
human yeah
[Music]
you